just a few million years after the Big
Bang the universe was almost completely
uniform no stars planets or galaxies had
formed yet in this simulation of the
early universe the green that we see is
on the gas initially discuss permeates
the universe as it traces a dissolution
of invisible dark matter as the gas
collapses at the center of dancer
aerials galaxies are born each of these
tiny spinning wheels is a proto galaxy
in this simulation when starts initial
form in the galaxies they're blue and as
the age they turn around it is also in
this protocol axis that the seeds of the
first massive black holes form we think
that these seeds may arrange in maps
from 100 to 100,000 times the mass of
the Sun over time the galaxies grow
larger either by acquiring mass from the
surrounding cosmic web shown here the
green pig filament or by merging with
other galaxies during a merger the two
galaxies collide are stripped of mass
and eventually become a larger galaxy at
the time of a merger many stars form
often condensing in bulges at the center
of the galaxy massive black holes evolve
in the same way as their galaxies debs
all mass from the center of the galaxy
or participate in mergers in fact black
hole's merge when the cores of the two
original galaxies become one when mass
is thrown into black hole some of it is
converted into energy it is then
radiated away is light in this phase we
say that galaxies have an active
galactic nucleus
the radiation of active galactic nuclei
is not visible in this simulation after
13 billion years of simulated time this
is Alex's similar to the Milky Way
contains about 50 billion stars the
total mass including dark matter is
about 1,000 billion times the mass of
the same the mass of the black hole in
center is about four million sore
muscles the simulation depict our best
knowledge to date of how interactions
between matter and black holes form
galaxies similar to our own